A few years back, I gave a talk at Chautauqua, in upstate New York, which, if you don't know what that is, starting in the 1870s, it was this high-minded lecture circuit, like TED Talks, but before the internet or Public Radio before the invention of radio. With a big religious component, which is how I fell into this long conversation about the literal word of the Bible.
几年前，我在纽约北部肖托夸做了一次演讲，如果你不知道那是什么，从19世纪70年代开始，那是一个高格调的演讲巡回活动，就像TED演讲，但在互联网出现之前，或者在广播发明之前的公共广播。它包含重要的宗教成分，这就是我陷入那场关于圣经字面意思的漫长谈话的原因。
It happened because the staffer who drove me to the airport was a retired Methodist preacher and associate pastor of one of the churches in Chautauqua, named John Jackson. And we had this hour and a half long drive.
那是由于送我去机场的工作人员是约翰·杰克逊，一位退休的卫理公会传教士，也是肖托夸教堂之一的副牧师。我们经历了一个半小时的车程。
And somehow, we got onto how he doesn't believe that every word of the Bible is literally true, which, if you're a Methodist, that's no big deal. And John said, that as he gets older, the literal words of the Bible seem less important to him than the big picture-- love your neighbor as yourself, and love God above all.
不知怎么的，我们谈到了他不相信圣经的每一个字都是字面真实，如果你是卫理公会教徒，那没什么大不了的。约翰说，随着他年龄增长，圣经的字面意思对他来说似乎没有大局观重要——爱人如己，爱神至上。
And I told John, I totally get the "love your neighbor as yourself" part of that. I can see how that can reshape just everything about how you treat others and really everything you do in your life in the world.
我告诉约翰，我完全理解“爱人如己”那部分。我能看出这如何重塑你对待他人以及你在世上所做的一切。
But I told him, like, I've never really understood, why is it important to love God above all? Do you know what I mean? If you do what God wants, and you try to be good-- you try to treat others right-- what difference does it make if you love God? What does God care?
但我告诉他，我从没真正理解，为什么爱神至上很重要？你明白我的意思吗？如果你做了神想要的事，尝试做一个好人——尝试正确对待他人——爱不爱神又有什么区别呢？神在乎吗？
And I got to ask John about a variation on this question, that I've wondered about for a couple of years, ever since the last time I was in synagogue. This was, I don't know, this was two or three years before this conversation. I hadn't been to synagogue in forever.
我问了约翰关于这个问题的一个变体，我思考这个问题已经好几年了，自从上次我去犹太教堂以来。那大约是在这次谈话的两三年前。我已经很久没去过犹太教堂了。
And it was the anniversary of my mom's death. And we're Jews, so you're supposed to go say Kaddish, this old prayer that's one of the central prayers in Judaism, at the anniversary of somebody's death. And so my dad and my stepmom and I were at one of the daily services that observant Jews go to every day in Baltimore, where I grew up.
那是母亲逝世的周年纪念日。我们是犹太人，所以按照规定要在亲人逝世周年那天诵读卡迪什，这是犹太教核心祈祷文之一。所以我和父亲、继母参加了巴尔的摩（我成长的地方）虔诚的犹太人每天都会参加的日常仪式。
And I always liked going to synagogue as a kid. We went a lot. And so it was nice going back. I know all the Hebrew prayers by heart. And I don't know if this is good or bad, but not having sat in a synagogue in over a decade, it really hit me how every day is a rerun. Do you know what I mean? They never do a new episode-- every day, the same words, same songs, in the same order, stretching back hundreds of years. They read a new part of the Bible, part of the Torah, some days, so there's that. But all the rest-- basically exactly the same every day.
我小时候一直喜欢去犹太教堂。我们经常去。所以回去感觉不错。我能背诵所有的希伯来语祈祷文。我不知道这好不好，但由于十多年没去过犹太教堂，我真的意识到每一天都是重播。你明白我的意思吗？他们从不演新剧集——每一天，同样的词，同样的歌，同样的顺序，延续了数百年。他们有时会读圣经的一新部分，托拉的一部分，所以还有那一项。但其余的——基本上每天都完全一样。
And everybody is singing and chanting. And I started looking in the prayer book on the side of the page with the English translation of the prayers, which I hadn't done in years. And I really was struck at how many of them-- the Amidah, the Ashrei, are about praising God at length. That's what the words mean, even the Kaddish, which you say over and over during services.
每个人都在歌唱和吟诵。我开始看祈祷书侧面页上的英语翻译，这我已经多年没做过了。我真的很震惊于其中有多少内容——如阿米达，阿什雷——都是关于长时间赞美神的。这就是这些词的意思，甚至是你在仪式中不断诵读的卡迪什。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[讲希伯来语]
It goes on and on. And the words basically are, may His great name be exalted and sanctified, blessed and praised, glorified and exalted, extolled and honored, adored and lauded, be the name of the Holy One. And that is what they have say when your mom dies-- comforting, huh? It's basically God is great, over and over, building to this beautiful line, really beautiful, that's basically: God is so great, it's beyond the power of any prayer or word or song or praise. It's beyond the power of language to capture it.
它没完没了。这些词的意思基本上是，愿祂伟大的名字被尊崇和圣化，被祝福和赞美，被荣耀和升华，被颂扬和尊荣，被崇拜和称颂，愿圣者的名字被赞美。这就是当你母亲去世时他们让你说的话——很安慰人，是吧？基本上就是神很伟大，一遍又一遍，最终引向这一行美丽的句子，真的很美，基本上就是：神如此伟大，超越了任何祈祷、言语、歌曲或赞美的力量。它超越了语言所能捕捉的范畴。
And it really hit me, sitting there. What does God get out of that? Why does he want us sitting down and telling him how great he is for 45 minutes a day? Is he that needy? If some parent demanded that of their kids-- OK, I want you to praise me for 45 minutes a day, every single day of your life, we would know they were nuts.
坐在那里，我真的深受触动。神从那里面得到了什么？他为什么要我们每天坐45分钟来告诉他他有多伟大？他那么需要吗？如果有些父母那样要求他们的孩子——好的，我想要你们每天、余生每一天都赞美我45分钟，我们就会知道他们疯了。
And it's like what I was saying to John-- what does God care if we love him? And John had such a lovely answer. He said, first off, he thinks lots of people make the mistake of picturing God as being like us, like humans, like he's somebody who we're calling on the phone, or something, when we're praying. But the way he sees it, he understands God to be all the values and principles that he sees in scripture-- the obligation to love each other, to be honest and decent in our dealings with each other, all of those things.
就像我跟约翰说的——如果我们要爱他，神会在乎吗？约翰给出了一个非常可爱的回答。他说，首先，他认为很多人犯了一个错误，把神想象成我们人类，就像我们打电话时联系的某个人。但在他看来，他将神理解为他在经文中看到的所有价值观和原则——爱彼此、在相互交往中诚实正直的义务，所有这些事情。
And when he's praising God, he said, that's what he's praising. He's basically re-pledging himself to those principles, which he loves. In other words, the literal words of the Bible, the literal words of the prayers, aren't as important as that pledge, a pledge to act a certain way in the world.
他说，当他在赞美神时，那就是他所赞美的。他基本上是在重新承诺遵循这些原则，他热爱这些原则。换句话说，圣经的字面词语，祈祷文的字面词语，并不像那个承诺那样重要，那个承诺是在世上以某种方式行事的承诺。
And reading and calling around in the days since we had that conversation, I've learned that other clergy-- Christian, Jewish, Muslim-- some of them say the same things, especially that God doesn't need our prayers. The prayers are for us. One of them told me the Kaddish is supposed to comfort me after my mom's death by pointing me to this idea of God's presence in the world, the goodness in the world, which, if I believed in God, I guess could be a comfort.
自从我们谈话后的这些天里，通过阅读和四处询问，我了解到其他神职人员——基督教、犹太教、穆斯林——有些人也这么说，特别是神不需要我们的祈祷。祈祷是为了我们自己。其中一人告诉我，卡迪什旨在通过向我指出神在世上的存在、世上的善良，来在我母亲去世后安慰我，如果我相信神，我想这可能是一种安慰。
But I don't believe. But weirdly, even without that, without believing any of the words, I do find it's a comfort to say the prayer. It's just it's familiar. It's familiar as the nursery rhymes my mom sang to me as a kid, as the Shema, the prayer that she had me and my sister say every night before we went to sleep. It's comforting, despite the fact that it's in another language and part of a doctrine I don't believe anymore.
但我并不相信。但奇怪的是，即使没有那种信仰，即使不相信任何字句，我也觉得诵读这篇祈祷文是一种安慰。它只是很熟悉。它像我母亲小时候唱给我的儿歌一样熟悉，像“示马”一样熟悉，那是她让我和姐姐每晚睡前诵读的祈祷文。尽管它是用另一种语言，且属于我不再相信的教义，但它依然令人安慰。
Just the fact of it handed to me by my parents and to them by their parents-- Freida and Lou and Melvin and Molly; and their parents before them-- David, Elizabeth, and Isidore; and people whose names I don't even know; and before them, their parents for hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of years; and standing in synagogue that day, standing and saying these words in unison with other mourners, it was comforting.
仅仅是它由父母传给我，由他们的父母传给他们——弗丽达、卢、梅尔文和莫莉；以及他们之前的父母——大卫、伊丽莎白和伊西多尔；还有我甚至不知道名字的人；以及他们之前几百几百几百年的父母；那天站在犹太教堂里，和其他哀悼者一起站着诵读这些词句，这令人安慰。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[讲希伯来语]
Today on our show, the sometimes very old words that we turn to for comfort in moments of adversity and at other times, they can be very random-- the novel Little Women, A Tribe Called Quest and other old school hip hop-- we have stories about each of those. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有时会求助于那些非常古老的词句以获得安慰，而在其他时候，它们可能非常随机——小说《小妇人》、探索部落组合和其他老派嘻哈——我们有关于每一个的故事。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1-- Go to the Mattresses. Shamyla always loved books. Back in 1989, like lots of other 11-year-olds, she also loved Punky Brewster and Paula Abdul. But her main thing was reading-- The Baby-Sitters Club books, Little House on the Prairie. It was all about words and books.
第一幕——去干活。沙米拉一直很爱书。回到1989年，像许多其他11岁的孩子一样，她也喜欢庞基·布鲁斯特和宝拉·阿巴杜。但她的主要兴趣是阅读——《保姆俱乐部》系列书，《草原小屋》。一切都与文字和书有关。
And then something happened, which totally changed what she read and how. Elna Baker talked to her. This is a story we first broadcast a few years ago. Today's show is a rerun. Here's Elna.
然后发生了一件事，彻底改变了她读什么以及如何读。埃尔娜·贝克采访了她。这是我们几年前首播的一个故事。今天的节目是重播。这是埃尔娜。
OK, so you meet somebody at a party, and they ask you, what's your favorite book? What's your answer?
好的，如果你在派对上遇到某人，他们问你，你最喜欢的书是什么？你的答案是什么？
My answer is Little Women is my all-time favorite book.
我的答案是《小妇人》是我一直以来最喜欢的书。
And then if they were to ask you, why? What would you say?
如果他们问你，为什么？你会怎么说？
Well, I probably would have a very long conversation with someone about that. But it goes back to the '90s, when I was living in Pakistan. And this was the only book that I had in my possession for a couple of years.
嗯，我可能会和某人就此进行很长的交谈。但这要追溯到90年代，当时我住在巴基斯坦。这是我几年来拥有的唯一一本书。
A couple of years, when she was basically held in captivity in Pakistan. I'll tell you how she found herself holed up with only one book in a minute. But first, here's how she ended up in captivity.
几年，当她基本上被扣押在巴基斯坦时。稍后我会告诉你她是如何发现自己只带着一本书被困在那里的。但首先，这是她最终被俘的过程。
She was raised in suburban Maryland. Her father was an economist, her mom a teacher. She went to an all-girls prep school. At 11, she learned her parents weren't her biological parents. Her mom, the oldest daughter in her family, couldn't have kids and really wanted to.
她在马里兰州郊区长大。她父亲是经济学家，母亲是老师。她上了一所全女子预科学校。11岁时，她得知父母不是她的亲生父母。她的母亲，家里最大的女儿，不能生育，但非常想要孩子。
And so Shamyla's family came up with a solution, one that's not unusual in Pakistan. Since her mom was the oldest, it was her younger sister's obligation to give her a child. And because of this family pressure and a sense of duty, the younger sister did it. But then it got complicated.
所以沙米拉的家庭想出了一个解决方案，这在巴基斯坦并不罕见。既然她母亲是最大的，那她妹妹有义务送给她一个孩子。由于这种家庭压力和责任感，妹妹照做了。但随后变得复杂起来。
Well, my adoptive parents had kids. They had a son. And then they had another son. And that really made my biological family confused and angry. And they were like, we gave you our child, and now you have your own children. Give us our daughter back.
嗯，我的养父母有了孩子。他们有一个儿子。然后他们又有了另一个儿子。这真的让我的亲生家庭感到困惑和愤怒。他们说，我们给了你我们的孩子，现在你有你自己的孩子了。把我们的女儿还给我们。
And my mom said, I'm not going to give her back. She's not a ball. I can't toss her back.
我母亲说，我不会还给她的。她不是一个球。我不能把她扔回去。
For years, they fought over this. When Shamyla was 12, on a visit home to Pakistan, her birth parents asked if they could take her on a trip. Her mom agreed, as a gesture of goodwill. It'd just be a week long, and she'd get to know her cousins, who were actually her brothers. And at first, it was really fun.
多年来，他们为此争吵。沙米拉12岁时，在一次回巴基斯坦的探亲中，她的亲生父母问能否带她去旅行。为了表示善意，她母亲同意了。那只会持续一周，她可以认识一下其实是她兄弟的表亲们。起初，这真的很有趣。
Until I got really sick at someone's house. And it turned out I had malaria. And what I didn't realize at the time was that they had taken me there on purpose, because it was way out in the country, where no one could find me.
直到我在某人家里病得很重。结果我得了疟疾。当时我没意识到的是，他们是故意把我带到那里的，因为那是偏远农村，没人能找到我。
Two weeks go by, then three. She's all better, asking when she can go back.
两周过去了，然后是三周。她痊愈了，问什么时候可以回去。
And they kept making excuses-- um, not-- you just need to wait. We have some other places to go. And I remember, at some point, my biological father taking me aside very kindly and saying, you know, we're your real family. They never loved you. We love you.
他们一直找借口——嗯，不要——你只需要等等。我们还有其他地方要去。我记得在某个时刻，我的亲生父亲非常友善地把我拉到一边说，你知道，我们才是你的真正家人。他们从来没爱过你。我们爱你。
They loved you like the way people love slippers, like an old, used pair of slippers. But they love their boys, because that's their blood. And we're your blood, and that's how we love you. So you're staying with us now.
他们爱你就像人们爱拖鞋那样，就像一双旧的、用过的拖鞋。但他们爱他们的男孩，因为那是他们的血脉。而我们是你的血脉，这就是我们爱你的方式。所以你现在和我们待在一起。
They don't let her leave, and she's really confused-- of course, my US parents love me. They must love me. But then, if they loved me, why aren't they coming to get me?
他们不让她离开，她真的感到困惑——当然，我的美国父母爱我。他们一定爱我。但如果他们爱我，为什么他们不来接我？
Unbeknownst to her, her US parents are trying to find out where she is. But no one will tell them. To make matters worse, her US parents are not legally Shamyla's parents. The adoption was never formal. She was just handed over. So they have no legal claim to their daughter, and there's nothing Shamyla could do. She was 12.
她不知道的是，她的美国父母正在试图查明她在哪里。但没人告诉他们。更糟糕的是，她的美国父母在法律上并不是沙米拉的父母。领养从未正式化。她只是被交给了他们。所以他们对女儿没有法律主张，沙米拉也无能为力。她才12岁。
Even if I fantasized about running away to another city and seeing other relatives, I was like, how will I do it? What will I do? Where will I get the money? How will I get on the train? How will I get on a plane? What will I do?
即使我幻想过逃到另一个城市去看望其他亲戚，我也想，我该怎么做？我会做什么？我从哪弄钱？我怎么坐火车？我怎么坐飞机？我该怎么办？
You were trapped.
你被困住了。
I was trapped, yeah.
我被困住了，是的。
She says her birth parents told her, when she was growing up, whenever they saw her, it was upsetting to them. They thought, she's too Americanized. They were incredibly traditional, even for Pakistan, which is already very patriarchal. Women are expected to be subordinate. And if their purity is questioned, like if they're even seen speaking to a man in a public place, their family's reputation could be ruined, and the whole family could be ostracized from the community for it.
她说她的亲生父母告诉她，当她长大时，只要看到她，他们就很心烦。他们认为，她太美国化了。即便对于巴基斯坦这样一个已经极其重男轻女的国家来说，他们也非常传统。女性被期望处于从属地位。如果她们的贞洁受到质疑，比如如果有人看到她们在公共场合与男性交谈，她们家庭的名声可能会被毁掉，整个家庭都可能因此被社区驱逐。
This is especially the case in Peshawar, where her birth parents lived. And Shamyla, a suburban Maryland tween, didn't understand that this was the world she lived in now. She says everything about the way she acted was wrong in their eyes. They didn't approve of the music she listened to or the books she read. They thought they were teaching her to be far too independent for a girl.
这在白沙瓦（她亲生父母居住的地方）尤其如此。而沙米拉，一个马里兰郊区的青春期少女，并不明白这就是她现在生活的世界。她说，在他们眼里，她的一切行为方式都是错的。他们不赞成她听的音乐或读的书。他们认为他们在教导她，对于一个女孩来说太独立了。
At this rate, she'd become promiscuous any day now. And since they didn't trust her not to be, they kept her under house arrest, confining her to a corner of the house that consisted of a bedroom and a bathroom. And they confiscated her cassettes and her books. Her birth father would lecture to her for hours.
照这个速度，她很快就会变得滥交。由于他们不相信她不会那样，他们把她软禁起来，把她限制在房子里由卧室和浴室组成的角落里。他们没收了她的磁带和书籍。她的亲生父亲会给她讲几个小时的课。
His favorite three topics were America is a bad place, especially for girls. American women are loose character and horrible. The second topic was your adopted family never really loved you, never. And the third topic was, so here's what you're going to do when you get married. These are your wifely duties, including your sexual obligations to your husband.
他最喜欢的三个话题是：美国是一个糟糕的地方，尤其是对女孩来说。美国女性品行不端，非常可怕。第二个话题是你的养父母从来没有真正爱过你，从来没有。第三个话题是，当你结婚时你该怎么做。这是你的妻子职责，包括你对丈夫的性义务。
He'd also lecture her about the rules she needed to follow. Some were the normal rules of an observant Muslim home. She couldn't go out without being covered, make eye contact, wear her hair down. Others were cultural-- she couldn't hug people; wear glasses when guests came over; speak English or Urdu, which would be seen as a sign of modernity. Only Pashto, the language of the region, was allowed.
他还会给她讲她需要遵守的规则。有些是虔诚穆斯林家庭的正常规则。她不能在不遮盖身体的情况下外出，不能有目光接触，不能披散头发。其他的则是文化性的——她不能拥抱别人；客人来时不能戴眼镜；不能说英语或乌尔都语，这被视为现代化的标志。只允许说普什图语，即该地区的语言。
She couldn't serve herself food before her brothers. She was barely allowed to eat. They thought she needed to be thin to get married, so they locked the fridge. She says, if she messed up, she was beaten with a kitchen squeegee, which cut her face open, or a walking stick. That was the worst one, she says.
她不能在兄弟之前给自己端食物。她几乎不被允许吃饭。他们认为她需要瘦一点才能结婚，所以他们锁上了冰箱。她说，如果她搞砸了，她会被厨房刮水板殴打，那把她的脸割开了，或者被拐杖殴打。她说那是最糟糕的一次。
The second worst one was with a golf club. And the third worst one was with cleats near my eye.
第二糟糕的是用高尔夫球杆。第三糟糕的是被高跟鞋踢到眼睛附近。
They took cleats and hit you with them.
他们用高跟鞋踢你。
And I think I got kicked.
我想我被踢了。
She asked me not to reach out to her birth parents to confirm these details, because she was worried for her safety. And I didn't. But members of her family here in the States confirmed that this is what her birth parents are like. And her mother and therapist corroborated that her story of being abused has always remained consistent.
她要求我不要联系她的亲生父母来证实这些细节，因为她担心自己的安全。我没那样做。但她在国美的家人成员证实了这就是她亲生父母的样子。她的母亲和治疗师证实，她关于被虐待的说法一直保持一致。
I remember, after every time they would beat me, I'd put an X on whatever calendar I had and be like, this will never happen again. I will be so good now, that this will never happen again.
我记得，每次他们打我之后，我都会在日历上打个叉，心想，这再也不会发生了。我现在会表现得非常好，这样这再也不会发生了。
Like, from this day forward, I'll finally be a good girl.
就像，从今天起，我终于会成为一个好女孩。
Yep.
是的。
Did you feel like you'd never be the girl they wanted you to be?
你觉得你永远无法成为他们想要的那个女孩吗？
No, I thought eventually, I'm going to get there. I just have to keep trying. I really thought that eventually, I'm going to become that person.
不，我想最终，我会做到的。我只需要继续努力。我真的以为最终我会变成那个人。
And you wanted to be that person?
你想要成为那个人吗？
I think that I thought I had no choice.
我想我以为我别无选择。
She wasn't just physically abused. As she got older, she says, she was also sexually abused by her brother. And finally, into this bleakness, comes a book, the book, Little Women.
她不仅受到身体虐待。随着年龄增长，她说，她还被兄弟性虐待。最后，在这片阴郁中，一本书出现了，那就是《小妇人》。
So one of my friends noticed the book at a book fair at our school. All these books had come from Singapore. And there was Little Women. I said, I know this book, and I want it. And I remember thinking, oh my god, I read that book when I was little. I had a huge, beautiful illustrated copy growing up. And I said to my friend Mirjana, I was like, Mirjana, can you please buy it? It's 10 rupees, and I'll pay you back.
我的一位朋友在学校的书展上注意到了这本书。所有这些书都来自新加坡。然后就是《小妇人》。我说，我知道这本书，我想要它。我记得我当时想，天哪，我小时候读过那本书。我成长过程中有一本巨大、精美的插图版。我对我朋友米里亚娜说，米里亚娜，你能帮我买下它吗？只要10卢比，我会还给你的。
She'd tried smuggling books home before, but she'd always been caught. She hid the book inside her mattress pad underneath the bed. And she broke it into sections, roughly eight piles, so that it didn't make the mattress stick up in any way.
她以前试过偷运书回家，但总是被抓。她把书藏在床下的床垫垫子里。她把书拆成若干部分，大约八堆，这样就不会使床垫鼓起来。
When she heard her family go out, she'd wait, and then carefully unzip the mattress pad, and take a section of the book out at a time. Whichever one she pulled out first, she read.
当她听到家人出去时，她会等待，然后小心翼翼地拉开床垫垫子，一次取出一部分。她先拿出哪一部分，就读哪一部分。
It was the book of my life. It was the only book I had to escape. It was the only book that I had to actually read over and over again. And I kind of memorized it.
这是我生命之书。这是我唯一能逃离的书。这是我唯一能一遍又一遍阅读的书。我基本上把它背下来了。
I'm going to read you like some quotes from the book.
我要给你读一些书里的引语。
OK.
好的。
And just interrupt if you know where it is or what this is about. And then I'm going to just random open book.
如果你知道它在哪里或者是关于什么的，就打断我。然后我只是随机打开书。
[CHUCKLING] This feels like a pop quiz.
[轻笑]这感觉像个突击测验。
Yeah, yeah. Ooh: Mercy on me. Beth loves Laurie, she said, sitting down in--
是的，是的。哦：可怜的我。贝丝爱着劳里，她说，坐在——
Oh, this is when Beth is ill. And Beth is changing, and she thinks the secret is that Beth is in love with Laurie.
哦，这是贝丝生病的时候。贝丝正在发生变化，她认为秘密是贝丝爱上了劳里。
Mrs. March and Jo were deep in their own affairs, when a sound from Meg made them look up to see her staring at her note.
马奇太太和乔正忙于自己的事情，这时梅格发出的声音让她们抬起头，看到她正盯着她的便条。
Oh, that's when-- [LAUGHING] that's when Meg has written to Mr. Brooke, and he actually writes back. But it was Laurie pretending to be Mr. Brooke.
哦，那是——[大笑]那是梅格写信给布鲁克先生的时候，他真的回信了。但那是劳里假装是布鲁克先生。
We did this eight times, and she's able to get everything I read within seconds.
我们这样做了八次，我读的每一段她都能在几秒钟内接上。
You're good at this.
你在这方面很在行。
[LAUGHING] I told you, I read this book over and over and over.
[大笑]我告诉过你，我一遍又一遍、反反复复地读这本书。
How many times?
读了多少遍？
Oh, hundreds. By now, it's probably thousands.
哦，几百遍。到现在，可能已经几千遍了。
If you haven't read Little Women, it's basically about four sisters, the March sisters. Meg, the oldest, is the responsible one. Jo is the rebel and the writer. Beth is sick. And Amy, the youngest, is a spoiled brat. Their father is serving in the Civil War, and their mother is raising them alone. The book follows these girls from childhood into adulthood.
如果你没读过《小妇人》，它基本讲的是四个姐妹，马奇姐妹。梅格，老大，是负责任的那个。乔是叛逆者和作家。贝丝生病了。艾米，最小的，是个被宠坏的调皮鬼。她们的父亲在参加内战，母亲独自抚养她们。这本书讲述了这些女孩从童年到成年的过程。
Were there parts of the book that you would just read over and over, like, your favorite parts?
书里有没有你反反复复读的部分，比如，你最喜欢的部分？
I loved reading the parts in the beginning, when the two sisters would talk to each other, Meg and Jo, and their bond. Because I didn't have a sister, and I had no one to talk to. And I really loved the scenes about parties and stuff.
我喜欢读开始的部分，两个姐妹梅格和乔互相交谈的时候，以及她们之间的联系。因为我没有姐妹，没人跟我说话。我真的很喜欢关于派对之类的场景。
She loved these scenes, because they mirrored her life in a really specific way. Her birth parents were upper middle class, and they wanted to use Shamyla to marry into a higher class. So they dressed her up and took her to social events to show her off. In the book, there are events like this that the March sisters go to.
她喜欢这些场景，因为它们以一种非常具体的方式映射了她的生活。她的亲生父母是中上阶层，他们想利用沙米拉嫁入更高阶层。所以他们给她打扮，带她去社交活动炫耀她。书里也有马奇姐妹参加的类似活动。
There's a chapter about Meg and Jo going to a party in the very beginning. And they're not out yet in society. And I was like, Oh my god, this 1860-something book is what's happening in Peshawar in 1990. Oh my god, it's the same thing. I'm not out yet in society, and I have to be very careful how I present myself.
开始有一章是关于梅格和乔去参加派对的。她们在社交界还未出道。我就想，哦，天哪，这本1860年左右的书里发生的事情，正在1990年的白沙瓦上演。哦，天哪，一模一样。我还没出道，我必须非常小心地展现自己。
In a way, Little Women was the perfect book for Shamyla's situation, because it's like a how-to for girls, a survival guide. Like most women who read the book, the sister Shamyla relates to the most is Jo. She was my favorite, too.
在某种程度上，《小妇人》是沙米拉处境的完美之书，因为它就像女孩的操作指南，生存指南。像大多数读这本书的女性一样，沙米拉最认同的姐妹是乔。她也是我最喜欢的。
I was raised in a strict religion, and my life was supposed to be about marriage and motherhood. And then Jo came into my orbit and showed me I could have ambition, and be improper, and break the rules. And I loved her for it. And that's how Shamyla felt. Jo helped Shamyla hold on to the identity her family was trying so hard to squash.
我在一个严格的宗教环境中长大，我的生活本应关于婚姻和母亲身份。然后乔进入了我的视野，向我展示我可以有野心，可以不循规蹈矩，可以打破规则。我为此爱她。沙米拉也是这样感受的。乔帮助沙米拉守住了她的家庭极力想压制的身份认同。
There's a part where Jo and Laurie go running. And Meg scolds her and says, when will you learn to be ladylike? And she says, I hope never. I always want to run, and I always want to romp. And I thought, me too. I never want to have to stop being spirited and independent.
有一部分是乔和劳里在奔跑。梅格责备她说，你什么时候才能学会像个淑女？她说，我希望永远不会。我一直想奔跑，一直想嬉戏。我想，我也是。我永远不想停止做一个充满活力和独立的人。
And I remember Jo had a temper in the book. And I thought, I have a temper, too. And she's working really hard to curb it, and I was like, I am, too. I didn't have any of the freedom Jo had. But in my heart, I was just as feisty and independent.
我记得书里的乔脾气暴躁。我想，我的脾气也暴躁。她正非常努力地克制它，我想，我也一样。我没有乔那样的自由。但在心里，我和她一样充满活力且独立。
So I think it's very funny when nowadays, my friends are like, well, you were so meek. And I was like, I was never meek. That's just a facade. [LAUGHING] I'm Jo. I get her.
所以我认为很有趣的是，现在朋友们说，好吧，你太温顺了。我就说，我从来都不温顺。那只是个伪装。[大笑]我是乔。我懂她。
But in a way, what's so interesting is it's so literally like your way of being Jo was reading about Jo. That's where you actually got to be Jo.
但有趣的是，你成为乔的方式如此字面地就是通过阅读关于乔的内容。那就是你真正能成为乔的地方。
Yeah, I couldn't really do anything else.
是的，我真的没法做别的。
In the book, Jo writes stories. Shamyla loved to write, too. But she says, the second year she was there, her birth father declared, girls aren't supposed to write, and took a notebook filled with her stories, and burned it in the backyard, and made her watch. In the book, Jo writes her stories alone in the attic. This gave Shamyla the idea to sneak into her bathroom with a fountain pen and paper and write.
在书里，乔写故事。沙米拉也爱写故事。但她说，她在那里第二年时，亲生父亲宣布，女孩不应该写作，没收了一本写满她故事的笔记本，并在后院烧了它，还让她看着。书里，乔独自在阁楼写她的故事。这给了沙米拉想法，偷偷溜进浴室，拿着钢笔和纸写。
And then I would wash all the ink off the paper, crumple up the wet paper, and throw it up the hole in the window mesh.
然后我会把纸上的墨水全部洗掉，揉皱湿纸，把它们扔出窗户网眼里的孔。
Wait, you would write the stories and then erase everything you'd written?
等等，你会写故事然后把你写的一切都擦掉？
So there was a hose that attached from the tub to the sink. And so I would take that hose and wash all the ink off.
有一根软管连接着浴缸和水槽。我会拿着软管把所有的墨水洗掉。
Down the drain of--
顺着下水道——
There was a floor drain, and I'd make sure that the floor drain was not blue with the blue ink [LAUGHING] and that there was no sign of ink that had fallen off the papers.
有一个地漏，我会确保地漏没有被蓝色墨水弄蓝，[大笑]并且没有任何墨水从纸上掉落的痕迹。
Shamyla knew how our family would react if they caught her writing or if they found her copy of Little Women and read any of it. Like, there's a boy in the book. His name is Laurie. He and Jo have an innocent flirtation. But Shamyla says, if her birth parents read that part, they'd think--
沙米拉知道如果他们发现她在写作，或者发现她那本《小妇人》并读到其中的任何内容，她的家人会如何反应。比如，书里有个男孩。他叫劳里。他和乔有一段天真的调情。但沙米拉说，如果她的亲生父母读到那部分，他们会认为——
You don't go over to adolescent boy's house ever. There's no innocence in this. In real life, Jo and Laurie would be doing very bad things. This is not right.
你永远不要去青春期男孩家里。这根本不天真。在现实生活中，乔和劳里会做非常坏的事情。这不对。
Well, they're saying, in real life, Jo and Laurie would be getting it on?
嗯，他们是在说，在现实生活中，乔和劳里会搞在一起？
Basically.
基本上。
I mean, that would have been a better book, right?
我的意思是，那会是本更好的书，对吧？
[LAUGHING]
[大笑]
I loved that. Oh my gosh I was like, in my fan fiction, I would write that.
我喜欢那个。哦天哪，我当时想，在我的同人小说里，我会写那个。
That's so funny.
那太搞笑了。
After a year, Shamyla's American mother was allowed to visit her. Shamyla told her what was happening. Her American mother cried and begged for her extended family to intervene and send Shamyla back to the States. But it was useless. Shamyla felt abandoned and hopeless. So she gave in, did her best to make herself into the obedient Pashtun girl they wanted her to be. There's a scene in the book, one I hated, because it was so sad, that Shamyla read over and over again.
一年后，沙米拉的美国母亲获准探望她。沙米拉告诉了她发生了什么。她的美国母亲哭了，恳求她的大家族干预并将沙米拉送回美国。但那是徒劳的。沙米拉感到被遗弃和绝望。所以她屈服了，尽最大努力让自己成为他们想要的顺从的普什图女孩。书里有一个场景，我讨厌它，因为它太悲伤了，沙米拉一遍又一遍地阅读。
I reread Beth's dying a lot, because there was this sense of helplessness. And I really understood that in a way that a lot of people don't. Because I knew, when something's inevitable, and it's going to happen, they keep saying, the tide is going out, in the book. And I was like, yeah, when the tide goes out, you just have to go with it. You can't fight it. I understood that on a level I couldn't even explain. I just knew what that meant.
我重读了贝丝去世的部分，因为有一种无助感。我以一种很多人不理解的方式真正理解了这一点。因为我知道，当某事不可避免，必然会发生时，他们在书里一直说，潮水正在退去。我就想，是的，当潮水退去时，你只能随波逐流。你无法抗争。我在一个我甚至无法解释的层面上理解这一点。我只是知道那意味着什么。
It sounds like their world feels so real to you.
听起来他们的世界对你来说感觉如此真实。
[LAUGHING] I know. It really does. I felt like I lived with them sometimes.
[大笑]我知道。真的如此。我觉得自己有时和他们住在一起。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
I felt like I was watching them, like I was the servant, or something, watching. I felt like I lived in the attic, and I could go downstairs and see them. They couldn't see me, but I could see them. And I would join the world. I would join in.
我觉得我在看着他们，就像我是仆人，或者什么的，在看。我觉得我住在阁楼里，我可以下楼去看他们。他们看不见我，但我看得见他们。我会加入这个世界。我会加入其中。
Her real world, of course was much darker. By the time she got to 17 or 18, she concluded that there's really only one way out to escape her family and maybe even have a happy life.
当然，她的真实世界要黑暗得多。到她17或18岁时，她断定逃离家人并可能拥有幸福生活只有一条路。
I was like, OK, so the way out is marriage. So I have to play this game to get married. And I started to actually kind of be like, OK, so in Little Women, you know how Meg goes to society dances, and wears her glove, and starts putting her hair up?
我想，好吧，那么出路就是婚姻。所以我必须玩这个游戏来结婚。我实际上开始想，好吧，在《小妇人》里，你知道梅格如何去参加社交舞会，戴上手套，开始把头发梳上去吗？
I was like, I can do this. I can do this to get the best possible way out. I was really thinking about how to create my life with someone else and what that would look like. And so I had stopped so much caring about going home or going back.
我想，我可以做到。我可以这样做来得到最好的出路。我真的在考虑如何与另一个人创造我的生活，那会是什么样子。所以我已经不再那么关心回家或回去的事情了。
And marriage is actually what the second part of Little Women is about. The second half of the book is very different from the first. It covers domestic duties and how the girls let go of their wild ways to become good wives.
而婚姻实际上是《小妇人》第二部分的内容。书的后半部分和前半部分非常不同。它涵盖了家庭责任，以及女孩们如何放下狂野的本性成为好妻子。
Shamyla, not a big fan of Part Two.
沙米拉不太喜欢第二部分。
The book, the second book, I remember thinking, I don't like this part. I like going back to their childhood and reading that part again.
这本书，第二本书，我记得当时想，我不喜欢这部分。我喜欢回到她们的童年，再读那部分。
Oh, the second part is the worst.
哦，第二部分是最糟糕的。
I know. It's so, so, so sad.
我知道。太、太、太悲伤了。
I think I'd really forgotten the message of the second half of the book. And it's kind of infuriating, when you realize how, in some ways, it feels almost like a propaganda for becoming the way you're supposed to be.
我想我真的忘记了书后半部分的信息。当你意识到在某些方面，它感觉几乎像是让你成为你“应该”成为的那种人的宣传品时，这有点让人愤怒。
Yeah. I remember thinking, when Meg gets married, they have a whole chapter about how she loses her freedom. And I was like, Oh god, I don't want that to be my story when I get married. I understood a lot of that, because that was what was being asked of me at that time, to give up, give up, give up, in order to be a woman to live in the society and be married and have a family.
是的。我记得当时想，梅格结婚时，他们有一整章关于她如何失去自由。我就想，哦，上帝，我不希望那成为我结婚时的故事。我非常理解其中的大部分内容，因为那时我正被要求这样做——放弃、放弃、放弃——以便成为一个在社会中生活、结婚并组建家庭的女人。
A friend at Shamyla's school told her she had a brother that Shamyla could marry, who would treat her well. So she began corresponding with him via her friend. But her family found out. And they were terrified that their reputation was going to be destroyed by it. Girls do not communicate directly with boys.
沙米拉学校的一位朋友告诉她，她有个兄弟可以嫁给沙米拉，他会善待她。于是她开始通过朋友与他通信。但她的家人发现了。他们担心自己的名声会被毁掉。女孩不能直接与男孩交流。
And they did what lots of families might do. They pulled her out of school and quickly started arranging her marriage to a 30-year-old man. As part of their damage control, they decided to send Shamyla away for a few weeks.
他们做了许多家庭可能会做的事。他们让她退学，并迅速开始安排她与一名30岁男子的婚姻。作为损害控制的一部分，他们决定把沙米拉送走几周。
But their only relatives who weren't in Peshawar were in America. So they made arrangements to send her back. And while she was there, her birth father and mother wanted her to learn new skills that would add to her bride price, the money the groom's family would be expected to pay them.
但他们唯一不在白沙瓦的亲戚在美国。所以他们做了安排把她送回去。当她在那里时，她的亲生父母想让她学习新的技能，这将增加她的聘礼，即新郎家庭被预期付给他们的钱。
He sent me with a whole list. He was like, you have to learn driving, shorthand, swimming. [LAUGHING]
他给了我一整张清单。他说，你必须学习开车、速记、游泳。[大笑]
It just seems like, after all the work they did to get you to stay, and also, their plans to marry you off, it just seems crazy that they would let you go back.
这看起来，在他们做了那么多努力让你留下，并且计划把你嫁出去之后，他们让你回去看起来太疯狂了。
Well it's funny, because she even said something crazy. She's like, if they're going to do anything to fix your face-- because remember, they cut my face open-- she's like, ask them if they can put a mole down there, like Cindy Crawford. And so I was like, OK, let's add mole to the list of things that will happen. [LAUGHING]
嗯，这很有趣，因为她甚至说了些疯狂的话。她说，如果要对你的脸做些什么修复——因为记住，他们割开了我的脸——她说，问问他们能不能在下面点个痣，像辛迪·克劳馥那样。所以我说，好吧，把痣加到将会发生的事情清单上。[大笑]
They send her to stay with her US parents. Her birth father is so confident that Shamyla is one of them now, that she'll obediently return to Pakistan. He doesn't question letting her go. A female chaperone traveled with her.
他们送她去和美国父母住在一起。她的亲生父亲非常自信沙米拉现在是他们的人了，她会顺从地回到巴基斯坦。他没有质疑让她回去。一位女性监护人陪同她旅行。
So we walked onto the tarmac. I climbed up in the plane. And as the plane took off, I just started crying nonstop. Because I knew I wasn't coming back. I just knew. I didn't know how I knew it. I don't know why I knew it. And I'm watching Pakistan slip away, and I'm like, I'm not going back here. It's never happening.
所以我们走上了停机坪。我爬上飞机。当飞机起飞时，我开始不停地哭。因为我知道我再也不会回来了。我只是知道。我不知道我怎么知道的。我不知道为什么我知道。看着巴基斯坦溜走，我想，我不会回到这里。这永远不会发生。
And was it relief?
那是解脱吗？
No. I was sad. I was really, really sad. And I was like, goodbye, life that I knew.
不。我很伤心。我真的、真的很伤心。我想，再见，我所知道的生活。
At first, she had a hard time coming back to America. She was in total culture shock. She could hardly speak English. She didn't recognize her little brothers. The internet existed now. It was like she'd woken up from a coma.
起初，她回到美国时度日艰难。她经历了完全的文化冲击。她几乎不会说英语。她认不出她的小兄弟们。互联网现在存在了。就像她从昏迷中醒来一样。
I remember thinking, I still like big hair. And everyone's like, that ended in 1989. No one does that anymore. And I was like, but I like that. They're like, no, now we straighten our hair. And I was like, I don't like that. Well, you have to.
我记得当时想，我还是喜欢蓬松的头发。每个人都说，那在1989年就结束了。没人再那样做了。我就说，但我喜欢那样。他们说，不，现在我们把头发拉直。我说，我不喜欢那样。嗯，你必须。
She enrolled in community college. But she'd been so indoctrinated, it was hard for her to just switch it off. She'd see women in skirts and catch herself judging them.
她进入社区大学就读。但她被洗脑太深了，很难一下子关掉它。她看到穿裙子的女性，会不由自主地评判她们。
For the first few years, she was a mess. Trying to switch off the ideology was nearly impossible. She started to see a therapist, who helped her process the extent of what happened to her.
最初几年，她一团糟。试图关掉这种意识形态几乎是不可能的。她开始看心理医生，这帮助她处理了发生在她身上的事情的程度。
There's something her mother said to me on the phone I can't stop thinking about. It's something she told her little sister once. Between you and me, we've ruined Shamyla's life.
她母亲在电话里对我说了一些我无法停止思考的话。这是她曾经对她小妹妹说过的话。你我之间，我们毁了沙米拉的生活。
It's been 23 years since she returned. Her life actually diverged from the second half of Little Women, the part she didn't like. She didn't get married, and she's independent. She runs her own practice as a therapist and social worker. She specifically works with people who suffer from trauma, because she understands it so well herself. But sometimes, she still returns to Little Women.
她回来已经23年了。她的生活实际上偏离了《小妇人》的后半部分，即她不喜欢的那个部分。她没有结婚，并且很独立。她经营着自己的心理治疗和社工诊所。她专门与受创伤的人一起工作，因为她自己非常了解这一点。但有时，她还是会回到《小妇人》。
Well, it comes up in different situations. I'll be like, OK, so-- the other day, I actually-- this is funny. My friend has twins. And she was telling me, like, god, I'm so tired, and they don't listen, and my husband is so busy. And I referred her to the chapter of Meg trying to discipline her twins. And I was like, read this. This will help you. [LAUGHING]
嗯，它在不同的情况下会出现。我会想，好吧，那么——那天，实际上——这很有趣。我的朋友有双胞胎。她告诉我说，天哪，我太累了，他们不听话，我丈夫太忙了。我推荐她读梅格试图管教她的双胞胎那一章。我说，读这个。这会有帮助。[大笑]
Wait, are you constantly-- do your friends have a joke or, like, Oh, not another Little Women reference.
等等，你是不是一直在——你的朋友们有没有开玩笑，或者说，哦，又一个《小妇人》的引用。
No, I think that they think it's funny that I like the book so much. But I don't think anyone really understands why.
不，我想他们觉得我这么喜欢这本书很有趣。但我认为没人真正理解为什么。
Wait, so it's like your only frame of reference?
等等，所以这是你唯一的参考框架？
Yeah.
是的。
When she's having a hard time or making a decision, she asks the question, opens the book, and whatever passage she reads, it's her answer from the March sisters. And she also has this ritual.
当她遇到困难或做决定时，她会问问题，打开书，无论她读到哪一段，那都是马奇姐妹给她的答案。她还有一个仪式。
So every year on my birthday, I find the corresponding age that I am for the chapter I am, and I read that.
所以每年在我生日那天，我都会找到与我年龄相对应的章节，然后阅读它。
In other words, chapter 30, when she turned 30; chapter 31, when she turned 31.
换句话说，30岁时读第30章；31岁时读第31章。
To be like, so what is this life-- this year going to be about in my life? What's it telling me?
就是想，那么今年我的生活会是关于什么的？它在告诉我什么？
So it's almost like your magic eight ball?
所以它几乎就像你的魔法8号球？
Yeah, kind of. It's like my Bible.
是的，某种程度上。它就像我的圣经。
What did you turn this year?
你今年多少岁了？
I'm 41.
我41岁。
And what chapter?
那是哪一章？
Oh Amy-- it's called Learning to Forget. It's when Laurie's trying to forget Jo, and he starts falling in love with Amy.
哦，艾米——它叫学会遗忘。那是劳里试图忘记乔的时候，他开始爱上艾米。
And how do you think that's going to relate to this year of be--
你觉得这和你这一年——
Maybe this year, finally someone's going to fall in love with me, [LAUGHING] the right one, not all the wrong ones.
也许今年，终于有人会爱上我了，[大笑]那个对的人，而不是所有错的人。
There are 47 chapters in Little Women. In six years, she'll turn 48. And she doesn't know what she'll do. She says maybe she'll start from the beginning again. And whereas the book used to be a way of escaping her room in Pakistan, now it's a way of returning to that world she built alone in her room. It's as if the March sisters are all still living there, and she's the one who left them behind.
《小妇人》有47章。六年内，她将满48岁。她不知道她会怎么做。她说也许她会从头再读一遍。而这本书过去是逃离她在巴基斯坦房间的一种方式，现在则是回到她在房间里独自构建的那个世界的一种方式。就好像马奇姐妹都还住在那里，而她是那个把她们留在身后的人。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. Shamyla told a version of this story herself on the storytelling podcast "Risk," which tapes for a live audience. You can hear that version and all those stories at risk-show.com. Coming up, Wu Tang Is For The Children, children are the future. So is Wu Tang the future? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。沙米拉自己在故事讲述播客“Risk”中讲述了这个故事的版本，该播客有现场观众。你可以在risk-show.com收听那个版本和所有那些故事。接下来，武当是为了孩子们，孩子是未来。那么武当是未来吗？稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续。
This is "This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- "The Weight of Words," stories about the words that people turn to for comfort or strength. We first aired this show in 2019. We've arrived at Act 2 of our show, Act 2-- Daddy Lessons.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于那个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目——“文字的分量”，关于人们求助于获得安慰或力量的文字的故事。我们在2019年首次播出了这个节目。我们来到了节目的第二幕，第二幕——爸爸的教训。
So the most recent bit of serious parenting that my dad did with me-- and I say this, realizing that this really might be the very last life lesson he might give me; we are both getting up there in years-- was a protracted month-long campaign to switch from Excel to Quicken, to keep track of my personal finances. He felt very strongly about this. And I just want to say, yes, the numbers add up the same, no matter what software you use.
所以，我父亲最近对我进行的最重要的一次教导——我说这句话时意识到，这确实可能是他给我的最后的人生教训；我们俩年龄都大了——是一场持续一个月的长篇大论，为了让我从Excel切换到Quicken，以记录我的个人财务。他对此感觉非常强烈。我只想说，是的，无论你使用什么软件，数字相加的结果是一样的。
But Quicken, I mean, don't get my dad started. He's a retired CPA. He had already trained me to save all my receipts. Please, that's basic. And he went on with this at such length, that at some point, I realized, Oh, switching software was not a piece of friendly financial advice. This was actual parenting happening.
但Quicken，我的意思是，别让我的父亲开始谈这个。他是一位退休的注册会计师。他已经训练我保存所有的收据。拜托，那是基础。他对此滔滔不绝，以至于在某个时刻，我意识到，哦，切换软件不是友好的财务建议。这是实际发生的育儿行为。
Not switching to Quicken meant an actual repudiation of him as a father. It would actually be a failure of parenthood. Parents try to shape who we are in their own image so often. They make sure their kids are exposed to whatever-- modern art, sports, nature, science, theater, whatever they love. They train them to be the world's greatest tennis player or golfer, that kind of thing.
不切换到Quicken意味着对我作为父亲的他的一种实际否定。那实际上将是一种育儿上的失败。父母经常试图按照他们自己的形象塑造我们。他们确保他们的孩子接触任何东西——现代艺术、体育、自然、科学、戏剧，任何他们热爱的东西。他们训练他们成为世界上最伟大的网球运动员或高尔夫球手之类的人。
My friend Adam came up with a scheme like that.
我的朋友亚当想出了一个那样的计划。
This is Neil Drumming. His friend Adam is Adam Mansbach, a writer.
这是尼尔·德鲁明。他的朋友亚当是亚当·曼斯巴赫，一位作家。
Adam is a DJ, a record collector, and he wanted his daughter Vivien to love music the way he loved music, exactly the way he loved music.
亚当是一位DJ、唱片收藏家，他希望他的女儿维维安能像他热爱音乐那样热爱音乐，完全按照他热爱音乐的方式。
One of the things I feel like I got right about parenting is that I never played Viv any kids music. Because I understood that any song that you played a two-year-old, a three-year-old, might become their favorite song, and then you would have to listen to it 20 times a day. So I never played her anything I wasn't willing to listen to 20 times a day. So she, from a very young age, was listening to a lot of music I liked.
我觉得我在育儿方面做对的一件事是，我从不放儿童音乐给维维听。因为我明白，你放给两岁、三岁孩子听的任何歌，都可能成为他们最喜欢的歌，然后你就得每天听20遍。所以我从不放我不愿意每天听20遍的东西。所以她从小就听很多我喜欢的音乐。
Is that a thing that you got right about parenting? Or is that a thing that you just did for yourself?
那是一件你做对的育儿事吗？还是你只是为你自己做的？
I mean, [LAUGHING] I mean, aren't the two synonymous really, Neil? I'm not sure what the difference is.
我的意思是，[大笑]我的意思是，尼尔，这两者不是同义词吗？我不确定有什么区别。
Adam likes '80s and '90s hip hop perhaps more than me, which is saying a lot. Anyway, he fed Vivien a steady diet of classic material-- A Tribe Called Quest, Public Enemy, Run-DMC. Das EFX.
亚当喜欢80年代和90年代的嘻哈音乐可能比我还多，这说明了很多。总之，他给维维安喂了一份稳定的经典材料——探索部落组合、人民公敌、Run-DMC。Das EFX。
There was probably a year, probably two years, where the Stetsasonic record In Full Gear got more play in our house than any other record. We may be the only household in North America that can say that, that in the year 2014, we listened to In Full Gear more than any other album.
可能有一年，甚至两年，Stetsasonic的唱片《In Full Gear》在我们家播放的次数比任何其他唱片都多。我们可能是北美唯一能这么说的家庭，即在2014年，我们听《In Full Gear》的次数超过了任何其他专辑。
[LAUGHING] What is that record, '88?
[大笑]那张唱片是什么，88年的？
Yeah, it came out in '88.
是的，它是88年出的。
This exposure therapy approach to parenting has been known to fail. I grew up surrounded by beds that were always made. But if you walked into my apartment now, you'd see no evidence of that. In Adam's case, though, it worked. He noticed that by the time she was six years old, Vivien could rap along to any hip hop song you played her.
这种接触疗法式的育儿方式众所周知会失败。我是在总是铺好的床周围长大的。但如果你现在走进我的公寓，你不会看到任何证据。但在亚当的案例中，它起作用了。他注意到当她六岁时，维维安可以随着你播放的任何嘻哈歌曲一起说唱。
She would memorize it, and she would be very much in the pocket and just not missing a beat. I remember one of the songs that we played a lot was The Choice is Yours," remixed by Black Sheep. I remember recording her just on my phone, doing the third verse of the song, the famous third verse of the song, Engine Engine Number 9.
她会把它背下来，而且非常有节奏感，不会错过任何一个节拍。我记得我们播放很多的一首歌是Black Sheep混音的《The Choice is Yours》。我记得录下她在我手机上表演这首歌的第三段，著名的第三段，Engine Engine Number 9。
If my train goes off the track, pick it up, pick it up, pick it up. Back on the seat, crispy and clean. You can try, but know what--
如果我的火车脱轨，把它捡起来，把它捡起来，把它捡起来。回到座位上，干脆利落。你可以试试，但知道什么——
And she had it perfectly down. And it's not an easy verse to do. And I remember sending it to our friend Jay Period, who in turn sent it to Dres, from Black Sheep. And he was like, Yo, this is incredible. Like, tell her-- give her my props.
她完全掌握了。而且那不是一段容易完成的。我记得把它发给我们朋友Jay Period，他转而把它发给了Black Sheep的Dres。他说，哟，这太不可思议了。告诉她——替我向她致敬。
And I was like, Yo, Viv, you're six, so this means nothing to you. But Dres from Black Sheep said that you're dope. This is his song.
我说，哟，维维，你才六岁，所以这对你来说没什么意义。但Black Sheep的Dres说你很棒。这是他的歌。
[MUSIC - "THE CHOICE IS YOURS" BY BLACK SHEEP]
[音乐 - Black Sheep的《THE CHOICE IS YOURS》]
(RAPPING) Engine, engine number 9, on the New York transit line, if my train goes off the track, pick it up, pick it up, pick it up. Come on.
(说唱) 引擎，引擎9号，在纽约公交线上，如果我的火车脱轨，把它捡起来，把它捡起来，把它捡起来。来吧。
Like a lot of guys our age, Adam tried his hand at being a rapper when he was younger. He joined a group. They made some songs that never quite went anywhere. He stayed in the hip hop world, though. He still has a lot of connections.
像我们这个年纪的很多人一样，亚当年轻时尝试过做说唱歌手。他加入了一个团体。他们制作了一些从没成名的歌。但他留在了嘻哈世界。他仍然有很多关系。
So he was thrilled to find out his daughter had some skills. And proud father that he is, he wanted more people to know. When another one of his entertainment industry buddies needed a theme song for a PBS Kids show he was making, called "Bug Bites," Adam jumped at the chance to write Vivien some original material.
所以他很激动地发现女儿有一些技巧。作为自豪的父亲，他想让更多人知道。当他的另一位娱乐行业好友需要他制作的一个PBS儿童节目《Bug Bites》的主题曲时，亚当抓住了这个机会为维维安创作了一些原创材料。
[MUSIC - "BUG BITES"]
[音乐 - 《BUG BITES》]
(RAPPING) Six legs, eight legs, fly and crawl. Let's get it, world, come one, come all. Bugs can teach us so much more about the world. Let's go explore! Some of these facts are incredible knowing, like bees keep flowers and vegetables growing.
(说唱) 六条腿，八条腿，飞和爬。让我们得到它，世界，来吧，全部来吧。虫子能教我们更多关于世界的事。去探索吧！其中一些事实令人难以置信，比如蜜蜂让花卉和蔬菜生长。
The show wound up not using the song. But Adam couldn't stop listening to it. He walked around playing it over and over in his headphones.
这个节目最终没用这首歌。但亚当听个不停。他戴着耳机一遍又一遍地播放它。
I mean, I knew she was skilled. But I sort of took it for granted. I was like, oh, that's just regular. Everybody can rhyme. Everybody I know can rhyme, you know? But I remember at that point being like, oh, you know what? This is really unique.
我的意思是，我知道她很熟练。但我把它当成了理所当然。我想，哦，那只是常规。每个人都能押韵。我认识的每个人都能押韵，你知道吗？但我记得那一刻心想，哦，你知道吗？这真的很独特。
Did this change your expectations for what this could be?
这改变了你对这可能会成为什么的期望吗？
Yeah, I think it opened-- it opened it up and made me want to maybe want to do more and see where we could take this.
是的，我想它打开了——它打开了局面，让我想要做更多，看看我们能把这个带到哪里。
And so they did.
于是他们就这样做了。
Step into my office and have a seat.
走进我的办公室，坐下来。
He and Vivien would plan out songs during the winters in California and record with his music industry friends back East during the summers. Writing for Vivien, Adam would layer in little in-jokes they shared or references that he knew his daughter would appreciate. Like when she was into Percy Jackson, he'd weave in the Greek gods. And when she was into Harry Potter, he worked that in.
他和维维安会在加州的冬天计划歌曲，并在夏天和他在东部的音乐行业朋友一起录音。为维维安写作时，亚当会层层叠叠地加入他们共享的小冷笑话或他知道女儿会欣赏的参考。就像她迷上珀西·杰克逊时，他会织入希腊神话。当她迷上哈利·波特时，他把它写了进去。
Yeah, I'm nice with my, like, Dumbledore, so what you want to rumble for?
是的，我的邓布利多很棒，所以你为什么要吵闹？
Vivien recorded under the moniker The Jazz Wolf, a name that she came up with. Her first real taste of mainstream exposure came by way of a song that Adam, who's originally from Massachusetts, wrote for her to perform in a hometown Boston accent.
维维安以“爵士狼”的名义录音，这是她自己想出的名字。她对主流曝光的第一次真正尝试是通过一首歌，亚当（原籍马萨诸塞州）写让她用波士顿家乡口音表演。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
(RAPPING) My name's Clarissa, I'm wicked pissah. That girl Amber, I had to dis her. She opened up a powder keg. You're speaking chowderhead. I'm a hot target. You work at Star Market. Nobody [INAUDIBLE].
(说唱) 我叫克拉丽莎，我坏透了。那个女孩琥珀，我不得不斥责她。她打开了一个火药桶。你是个蠢货。我是个热门目标。你在Star Market工作。没有人[听不清]。
They made a video for the song, which made it onto the home page of the popular humor website Funny or Die. But "Much Lobstah" was more like a comedy bit than a banger, more DJ Jazzy Jeff and the Fresh Prince than it was Eric B and Rakim. Adam didn't feel the song was representative of how he imagined Vivien as an artist.
他们为这首歌制作了一个视频，登上了热门幽默网站Funny or Die的主页。但《Much Lobstah》更像是一个喜剧片段而不是热门单曲，更多是DJ Jazzy Jeff和Fresh Prince风格，而不是Eric B和Rakim风格。亚当觉得这首歌并不代表他作为艺术家想象中的维维安。
It was a funny song, but it was a funny song. It wasn't truly indicative of her skills as an emcee, because it was more focused on dropping Massachusetts-centric jokes.
这是一首有趣的歌，但它只是首有趣的歌。它并不真正代表她作为MC的技巧，因为它更关注抛出马萨诸塞州中心的笑话。
(RAPPING) Eat a grinder, drink a beer. Then I slap a critic. You're off the rails like Teddy was at Chappaquiddick. [BLAST]
(说唱) 吃个研磨机，喝杯啤酒。然后我给评论家一巴掌。你像泰迪在查帕奎迪克那样脱轨了。[爆炸]
Adam had told me that his kid rapped early on. But I didn't understand how serious the two of them were about this until September of 2017, when I received an email from Adam with no subject heading. Attached to the email were two remarkably well-produced songs, described in the body of the email simply as, Jazz Wolf Heat Rocks.
亚当告诉我他孩子很早就在说唱。但在2017年9月我收到亚当发的一封没有主题的邮件之前，我不明白他们俩对这个有多认真。邮件附件里是两首制作得非常好的歌，在邮件正文中简述为“爵士狼热石”。
One of these so-called Heat Rocks featured Vivien, who I had met once only briefly, but knew to be a small, blond White girl, rapping over a fluttery dancehall rhythm in full-on Jamaican patois.
其中一首所谓的热石特色是维维安，我只见过她一次，但知道是一个个子娇小、金发的白人女孩，在飘忽的舞厅节奏上用纯正的牙买加方言说唱。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
(RAPPING) Jazz Wolf for better rhyme, sound girl better rhyme, get your gun, where you come, fire bun, get it done. Should we test it? None. We are [INAUDIBLE]. Champion. A champion. Swim over land and walk the ocean. Sound girl, we take apart in slow motion.
(说唱) 爵士狼更好的押韵，音响女孩更好的押韵，拿上你的枪，你来自哪里，开火，把它做好。我们应该测试一下吗？没有。我们是[听不清]。冠军。冠军。跨越陆地游泳，走过海洋。音响女孩，我们把它慢动作分解。
Did listening to this reggae song, penned by a best-selling Jewish author for his nine-year-old and most likely, recorded in or near his house on Martha's Vineyard, make me feel uncomfortable? Yeah, sure, a little. But I've been listening to hip hop a long time. And between all the sampling and biting and flipping styles, I've kind of made my peace with cultural appropriation. All I ask is that you give credit where credit is due and that you do your due diligence.
听这首由一位畅销犹太作家为他九岁孩子创作的雷鬼歌曲，而且很可能是在他家附近录制的，让我感到不舒服吗？是的，当然，有点。但我听嘻哈音乐很久了。在所有的采样、剽窃和翻转风格之间，我已经与文化挪用达成了和解。我所要求的一切就是你要给予应有的认可，并且你要做好尽职调查。
You know, Neil, I should say that I had some misgivings about the song.
你知道，尼尔，我应该说我对这首歌有些顾虑。
[LAUGHING] I was going to ask.
[大笑]我正想问。
I definitely-- really, the first thing I did was send it to every Jamaican I knew.
我绝对——我做的第一件事就是把它发给我认识的每一个牙买加人。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
I'd be like, yo, so what do you think about this?
我会说，哟，那你对这个怎么看？
Anyway, the point is, it wasn't just me and some Caribbean Islanders who got this email. Adam was stepping up Vivien's game and had sent the Jazz Wolf de facto demo to just about every music industry contact he had. To a certain degree, it worked. Friends praised his daughter's music.
总之，关键是，不仅仅是我和一些加勒比岛民收到了这封邮件。亚当在提升维维安的水平，并把爵士狼的事实演示发给了他所有的音乐行业联系人。在某种程度上，它起作用了。朋友们称赞他女儿的音乐。
Artists who Adam admired wanted to record with her. A big player in the music industry who had a hand in discovering Lauryn Hill suggested that they record more songs for a legitimate demo. Bolstered by all this interest, Adam set out to write Vivien something really special. It was the kind of thing he'd have written for himself back in his rapping days-- multi-syllabic, rapid fire, a real showpiece, designed to take the Jazz Wolf all the way to the next level. He was on a business trip, when the ghost writer in him really took over.
亚当钦佩的艺术家想和她录音。一位曾参与发现劳琳·希尔的音乐行业大人物建议他们录制更多的歌作为正式演示。在所有这些兴趣的激励下，亚当着手为维维安写一些真正特别的东西。这是他当年自己说唱时会写的东西——多音节、快速火炮、真正的展示品，旨在将爵士狼带到下一个水平。他出差时，他心中的代笔人接管了工作。
And I remember I had to go away for a week. I was in Chicago, doing some stuff. And I writing bars for her. And I was really trying to write the most complicated, difficult verses I could. Because I knew she could handle it, and I was like, this is going to be really fun.
我记得我得离开一周。我在芝加哥，做些事。我正在为她写词。我确实在努力写出我能写出的最复杂、最困难的段落。因为我知道她能应付，我想，这会非常有趣。
And I came back with the song. And we rehearsed it for a long time. We got a beat from Dug Infinite, an illustrious producer, who worked with Common and all kinds of people. And Viv had been practicing it for weeks.
我带着歌回来了。我们排练了很长时间。我们从杰出的制作人Dug Infinite那里得到了一段节拍，他曾与Common和各种各样的人合作。维维已经练习了几周了。
And we had plans to go to his house and record it. She was nine at the time, I remember, because the chorus of the song played with the fact that she was nine. We flipped the chorus from nine millimeter goes bang. And it was like, wa da da dang, wa da da da dang. Hey, listen, 'cause I'm nine, and I kick enough slang.
我们计划去他家录音。记得她那时九岁，因为歌的合唱部分玩了一个梗，关于她九岁。我们翻转了《9毫米响个不停》的合唱部分。就像，哒哒哒，哒哒哒。嘿，听着，因为我九岁了，而且我踢得够多了。
But despite all Adam's craft in preparation, there was an unforeseen, but not unforeseeable issue with the talent.
但尽管亚当精心制作和准备，在人才方面出现了一个未预见到但并非不可预见的问题。
She hadn't slept that night. I think we had a new baby. Viv has two younger sisters, and the older of the two at that time was only a few months old and was up, crying. And so Viv was on no sleep.
她那天晚上没睡。我想我们有个新生儿。维维有两个更小的妹妹，两个妹妹中较大的那个当时才几个月大，一直在哭。所以维维根本没睡觉。
And I remember we got to the studio really early. And she was just exhausted and not really at her peak. And it was difficult for her to get it down. And we kind of called it. We cut it short. I was like, you know what? Let's come back another day, Dug, because this isn't it.
我记得我们很早就到了录音室。她只是精疲力竭，没达到巅峰。这让她很难完成。我们算是取消了。我说，你知道吗？Dug，我们改天再来吧，因为这不行。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
[LAUGHING]
[大笑]
No, I'm sorry. I didn't mean to be like that.
不，对不起。我不是那个意思。
Nah, are you kidding me? It's not your fault.
不，你在开玩笑吗？那不是你的错。
That's Vivien. She was in the studio with her dad during this interview. She's 11 now.
那是维维安。在这次采访中，她和父亲在录音室里。她现在11岁了。
Right, so I remember coming back from there. And Viv was tired. And in the car, she told me. She was like, Papa, you know, I'm just not that into this right now, something along those lines. Like, I'm not into you writing me these rap songs right now.
对，所以我记得从那里回来。维维很累。在车里，她告诉了我。她说，爸爸，你知道，我现在真的不太想做这个，大意是这样。就像，我现在不想让你给我写这些说唱歌曲了。
Vivian, do you remember this moment at all, this night?
维维安，你还记得这一刻吗，这个晚上？
I did. And I think that the reason I told him then was that-- this is going to sound really stupid. But I thought that because-- I think he would be less angry if he knew I was tired and didn't want to argue.
我记得。我想我当时告诉他是因为——这听起来会很蠢。但我认为，因为——我想如果他知道我很累而且不想争论，他会没那么生气。
So you had already come to this decision?
所以你已经做出了这个决定？
Yeah. I mean, we hadn't talked about it, but I'd already gone through it in my head what I was trying to say.
是的。我的意思是，我们没讨论过，但我已经在脑子里经历过我想说的话。
OK, let's back up a bit. Vivien's dissatisfaction with how Adam was steeling her rap career goes back long before this night, back many car rides, in fact. She recalls trying to listen to new music while riding with her dad.
好吧，让我们往回退一点。维维安对亚当如何为她打造说唱事业的不满，追溯到那个晚上之前很久，事实上是许多次车程。她回想起当和爸爸一起开车时尝试听新音乐。
Just flipping through radio stations in the car and him turning on a radio station, and I was like, oh yeah, this one. He's like, Oh, that's hot trash. We're not listening to that.
只是在车里翻电台，他打开一个电台，我当时想，哦对了，这个。他说，哦，那是热垃圾。我们不听那个。
You see, Adam didn't realize this, but even while she'd been sharing his love of hip hop, Vivien had been developing her own taste. She'd started to enjoy more contemporary music, God forbid, even pop music-- Taylor Swift, and later, Kesha and Nicki Minaj and Cardi B. But she'd been listening to music through Adam's ears long enough to understand and internalize just how much he wouldn't approve.
你看，亚当没意识到这一点，但即使维维安一直分享他对嘻哈的热爱，她也一直在培养自己的品味。她开始享受更现代的音乐，天哪，甚至流行音乐——泰勒·斯威夫特，后来是Kesha、妮琪·米娜和卡迪·B。但她听音乐透过亚当的耳朵听得够久，足以理解并内化他会有多不赞同。
So you felt like there were things that you liked that you couldn't tell him about?
所以你觉得有些你喜欢的东西你不能告诉他？
No. Well, there were things that I liked that I could tell him about, but that I didn't feel like there was any point to telling him about, because he would tell me all the errors. And I would be like, yo, like, listen to this person's voice. Or like, this song is so good; and play it. And then afterward, Papa would be like, you want to hear something good? And run into where he keeps his records, and I'm like, oh, gosh.
不。嗯，有些东西我喜欢但可以告诉他，但我觉得告诉他没有任何意义，因为他会告诉我所有的错误。我会说，哟，就像，听听这个人的声音。或者说，这首歌太好了；然后播放。然后之后，爸爸会说，想听点好的吗？然后跑到他存放唱片的地方，我就想，哦，天哪。
Do you remember any examples of this?
你记得这方面的任何例子吗？
Uh, one time, I was playing him a song from Hamilton, where someone was rapping really fast. And I played it, and he just half listened. And then afterward, he's like, you want to hear really fast rapping?
呃，有一次，我在给他放《汉密尔顿》里的一首歌，里面有人说唱得很快。我放了，他只是半听着。然后之后，他说，你想听听真正快速的说唱吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
And I'm like, oh god.
我心想，哦，上帝。
What did you play her, Adam?
你给她放了什么，亚当？
Well, all right. Let me back up for a second.
好吧，好吧。让我退后一步。
Sorry, Papa.
对不起，爸爸。
At the risk of getting on my soapbox and with the full understanding, this is never going to make it actually into this piece, my thing with Hamilton was like, cool. Hamilton is fine. My issue with it is that a billion people who have no interest--
冒着站上肥皂箱的风险，并且完全理解这一点永远不会真的进入这篇报道，我对《汉密尔顿》的感觉就像是，酷。汉密尔顿很好。我的问题是，十亿个没兴趣的人——
Here, Adam's critique of Hamilton, while spirited, is mostly remarkable, in that he somehow manages to vehemently object to the musical's popularity while simultaneously namedropping his friendship with one of its former stars, Daveed Diggs. Vivien didn't just want to feel free to listen to Hamilton in the car on the way to school. She wanted to incorporate all of her newfound influences into her own music.
这里，亚当对《汉密尔顿》的批评，虽然很有精神，但大多引人注目的是，他竟然一方面强烈反对这部音乐剧的流行，一方面同时顺带提到他与其中一位前明星戴维德·迪格斯的友谊。维维安不仅想在去学校的车上自由地听《汉密尔顿》。她想将她所有新发现的影响力融入到自己的音乐中。
I felt like-- I mean, it's really cool that I'm doing all Papa's cool stuff. But if I have this voice, and I have access to this recording, can't I use it to do things that are more my style?
但说唱是进入它的方式？
It's not all that surprising that someone Vivien's age would eventually diverge from the path her father set her on when she was six. And this wasn't even the first time Vivien had stood up to her dad. She's usually pretty outspoken. But she told me this time was different, that she had been more scared than usual to speak her mind and that it took her months to work up the courage.
维维安这个年纪的人最终会偏离她父亲在她六岁时为她设定的道路，这并不奇怪。这甚至不是维维安第一次反抗她爸爸。她通常很直言不讳。但她告诉我这次不同，她比平时更害怕表达自己的想法，她花了几个月才鼓起勇气。
She was right to be concerned. Adam took it noticeably hard. To hear him tell it, he interpreted this slight rejection as a sort of referendum on his parenting.
她担心得有道理。亚当受到了明显的打击。在他看来，他将这种轻微的拒绝视为对他育儿的一种公投。
I felt a certain kind of sadness on a couple of levels-- first, disappointment in myself for getting carried away and making her feel uncomfortable or making her feel like an unwilling participant in this project. And also, just a sense of letdown that wow, maybe we were no longer going to be hanging out after dinner, playing instrumentals, and fitting rhymes to them, and practicing, and rehearsing, and cutting scratch demos, and that kind of thing. Because it was something that brought me a lot of joy, both reveling in her skill, but really more than anything, just spending time together, and that feeling of collaboration-- which is wonderful when you find it with anybody. But when you find it with your own kid, it's magical.
我在几个层面上感到一种悲伤——首先，对自己感到失望，因为太得意忘形，让她感到不舒服，或者让她感觉自己是这个项目的非自愿参与者。还有一种失落感，哇，也许我们以后不再会晚餐后待在一起，播放伴奏，填入押韵，练习，排练，剪辑刮盘演示，之类的事情了。因为那是一件给我带来很多快乐的事，既沉浸在她的技巧中，但更重要的是，只是花时间在一起，那种协作的感觉——当你和任何人找到这种感觉时都很美妙。但当你和自己的孩子找到这种感觉时，那是魔法。
I mean, this is me, like armchair psychotherapist. But was there any part of you that was deflecting some energy into this in a way that maybe was more for you than for Vivien?
我的意思是，这是我，像个业余心理治疗师。但你有没有一部分能量是以某种可能更多是为了你而不是为了维维安的方式在偏转？
That's a great question. I mean, the whole period of time that we're talking about is fairly tumultuous. I mean, from when Viv was six until now--
这是个好问题。我的意思是，我们谈论的整个时期相当动荡。我的意思是，从维维六岁到现在——
Five years.
五年。
Five years-- I mean, that's a period of time that covers her mom and I splitting up. It covers a new relationship, two new babies. So yeah, you probably have a point there, I mean, at least in the sense of this being something that was purely fun and exciting and didn't feel heavy in any way.
五年——我的意思是，那段时间涵盖了她妈妈和我分开。它涵盖了一段新恋情，两个新生儿。所以是的，你可能说得对，我的意思是，至少在某种意义上，这是一种纯粹有趣、令人兴奋且没有任何负担的东西。
They never did finish that song. Adam and Vivien's magical collaboration was not infinitely sustainable. But so what?
他们确实没完成那首歌。亚当和维维安的魔法协作不是无限可持续的。但那又怎样？
When everything was happening in our family, also, it was a way for me to connect with Papa. And also, after we'd had a lot of fun kicking rhymes, we could talk about the more important stuff. He could be like, how do you feel? How about the new baby? And I feel like it just-- I would be a lot less close with Papa now if we hadn't spent so much time together doing that. I wouldn't be coming into your room and be like, let's talk about this.
当家里发生这一切时，这也成了我与爸爸联系的一种方式。而且，在我们在踢押韵中玩得很开心之后，我们可以谈论更重要的事情。他可以说，你感觉如何？那个新生儿怎么样？我觉得它只是——如果不是因为我们花了那么多时间在一起做那个，我现在会离爸爸远得多。我就不会走进你的房间说，我们谈谈这个。
But the rapping was the way into it?
但说唱是进入其中的途径吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That makes me happy. I'm glad to hear that.
那让我很高兴。很高兴听到这个。
Recently, Vivien has been getting more into singing. She writes her own poems and adapts them into songs. She's written a few, and she thinks she could be good at it with a little time a little help.
最近，维维安越来越喜欢唱歌了。她写自己的诗并把它们改编成歌曲。她写了几首，她认为只要有一点时间一点帮助她就能做好。
I wouldn't say that I totally want Papa to be out of my career. As a singer, he's super supportive. And he's obviously the one with all the connections. But--
我不会说我完全想让爸爸离开我的事业。作为歌手，他超级支持我。而且他显然是那个有所有关系的人。但——
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
Practical-- that was very practical of you. That's smart.
实际——你刚才太实际了。那很聪明。
Yes. [LAUGHING] It's was very cold-blooded right there.
是的。[大笑]那真是冷酷无情。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
I'm a father myself. It's a new thing, so new, In fact, that all I can say definitively about the experience so far is that I am terrified every single day about what's coming. I look around to my friends, as scared people do. And the thing that Adam pulled off gives me some hope.
我自己也是个父亲。这是一件新鲜事，如此新鲜，事实上，到目前为止关于这段经历我能肯定的唯一一点是，我每天对即将到来的一切都感到恐惧。我和朋友们一样向四周望去，就像害怕的人那样。亚当完成的事给了我一些希望。
He found an easy way to be with his daughter through difficult times. He constructed something fun that they could share, no matter what else was swirling around them. And the outcome was perhaps the best one that any parent can imagine-- Vivien got it. At least for a little while, she was right there with him.
他在困难时期找到了一种与女儿在一起的简单方式。他构建了一些有趣的东西，让他们可以分享，无论周围有什么东西在汹涌。结果可能是任何父母能想象到的最好的结果——维维安懂了。至少有一段时间，她就在他身边。
What do you guys remember? Do you guys remember-- does anyone remember the super complicated song?
你们记得什么？你们记得——有人记得那首超级复杂的歌吗？
Yeah. [LAUGHING] I [INAUDIBLE].
是的。[大笑]我[听不清]。
I remember only the second verse, though.
但我只记得第二段。
Oh, do it.
哦，来吧。
Wait. Let me just do it in my head for a second.
等等。让我在脑子里过一遍。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You want me to do it now, Poppy?
你想让我现在做吗，爸爸？
Yeah, do it.
是的，做吧。
(RAPPING) [INAUDIBLE] solemnly swear to scar you horribly. Destiny calling me. Honestly rappers a bloodily body. They're haunting me. But they can't do much harm to me. I'm open like a pharmacy. Karmically, I'm untouchable, highly combustible. I can't remember the rest right now.
(说唱) [听不清]庄严宣誓要给你留下可怕的伤疤。命运召唤我。老实说，说唱歌手们身体血淋淋的。他们在困扰我。但他们不能对我造成太多伤害。我像药房一样开放。业力上，我是不可触碰的，高度易燃的。我现在不记得其余的部分了。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
The Jazz Wolf is back. What?
爵士狼回来了。什么？
Stop.
停。
Neil Drumming.
尼尔·德鲁明。
I know a lot about small talk, because I worked in an office. And there's a lot of small talk that goes on. There's all these different forms of it. There's water cooler small talk, and there's elevator small talk, which actually isn't even that bad. Because most people think elevator small talk is the worst kind. But actually, I think it's OK, because it's finite. You know it's going to end at a certain point--
我知道很多关于闲聊的事，因为我在办公室工作。有很多闲聊在进行。它有各种不同的形式。有饮水机闲聊，还有电梯闲聊，其实一点也不坏。因为大多数人认为电梯闲聊是最糟糕的一种。但其实，我认为还可以，因为它有限。你知道它在某个点会结束——
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
--which I appreciate very much. And then there's even bathroom small talk where I work, which is the worst thing you're ever going to experience in your entire life.
——我非常感激这一点。然后还有我工作地方的洗手间闲聊，那绝对是你一生中会经历的最糟糕的事情。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
They'll be people small-talking through the stalls. I actually have some audio of small talk to play for you.
人们会在隔间里闲聊。我其实有一些闲聊的音频要放给你听。
Coffee is on its way. Here is a special selection of the Viking blend. And I have to get back to work.
咖啡在路上了。这是维京拼配的特别精选。我得回去工作了。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
So that's what happened in my office. Almost every day, that seems to happen, actually. We know we're drinking coffee. It's being made. But for some reason, when you do small talk, when you're caught in the trap of small talk, you feel you just had to talk about what's immediately happening in front of you, even though it's so obvious. And it's not even his fault. You know what I mean? It just-- everyone does it.
所以那就是我办公室发生的事。几乎每天，看起来似乎都会发生。我们知道我们在喝咖啡。它正在被制作。但出于某种原因，当你进行闲聊，当你陷入闲聊的陷阱时，你感觉你不得不谈论眼前立即发生的事情，即使它是如此明显。这甚至不是他的错。你明白我的意思吗？它只是——每个人都这样做。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
And so I can't take it anymore. So I devised The Rundown to eliminate small talk forever from the world. I want it to be done with. The Rundown is what it's supposed to do. The goal Of the Rundown is it's supposed to turn conversations from the conversations you're supposed to be having to the conversations you want to be having. OK?
所以我再也受不了了。所以我设计了“简报”来永远从世界上消除闲聊。我希望它被终结。简报是它应该做的。简报的目标是它应该把你们应该进行的对话变成你们想要进行的对话。好吗？
And so I also have an example of The Rundown. I went to a movie. And there was a ticket guy selling tickets. And I just started talking to him. So it can be done on anyone.
所以我也有一个简报的例子。我去看电影。有个售票员在卖票。我只是开始和他说话。所以它可以在任何人身上完成。
I had ramen noodles for breakfast.
我早餐吃了拉面。
The $0.25 ones or did you pay-- or the fancy ones?
25美分的还是你买了——或者高档的？
I didn't pay for them. My girlfriend bought them.
我没付钱。我女朋友买的。
OK, and so you're thinking small talk. You're going to go after the ramen noodles, right? Like, what kind of ramen noodles? What hot water, meat? Something like that-- but if you're doing The Rundown, you just seize on the most interesting part of the conversation, OK?
好吧，所以你在考虑闲聊，你要去抓拉面，对吧？比如，什么样的拉面？什么热水，肉？之类的——但如果你在做简报，你就只抓住对话中最有趣的部分，好吗？
And so he did give me a very, very valuable clue. He gave me this girlfriend, wonderful girlfriend, character to work with, OK? From that, you can proceed to--
所以他确实给了我一个非常、非常有价值的线索。他给了我这个女朋友，美妙的女朋友，角色去处理，好吗？从那里，你可以继续——
Are you in love?
你恋爱了吗？
I love her.
我爱她。
We don't know if-- you're not in love?
我们不知道是否——你没恋爱？
Oh, well, I think, yeah. I am definitely in love.
哦，嗯，我想，是的。我绝对恋爱了。
OK, so that's a little bit more to go with, right? Now we know he's capable of love--
好吧，所以这多了一些东西可以聊，对吧？现在我们知道他有能力爱——
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
--which is a lot more than knowing that he just had ramen noodles, right? And from there, OK, the possibilities just open up wide. You can pretty much go for anything now. So then you just keep going.
——这比知道他只是吃了拉面要多得多，对吧？从那里，好吧，可能性大开。你现在几乎可以去聊任何事情了。所以你就继续聊。
How many one-night stands have you had?
你有过多少次一夜情？
Uh, well, I don't-- I know how many girls I've been with, but I don't-- I never really counted which of them are one-night stands exactly.
呃，嗯，我不知道——我知道我和多少个女孩在一起过，但我没有——我从来没真正计算过她们中有多少人是一夜情。
How many girls?
多少女孩？
44 and 1/2.
44个半。
44 and 1/2. How many virgins?
44个半。多少个处女？
I don't know. Estimate-- roughly, probably four or five.
我不知道。估计——大概，可能有四个或五个。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
OK, so you might think, how many virgins, is an inappropriate question. But I actually think it's the perfect fallback, if you have nothing else to ask. You know what I mean? Because--
好吧，所以你可能会想，多少个处女，是个不合适的问题。但我其实认为它是完美的后备，如果你没有别的话可问。你明白我的意思吗？因为——
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
--as you can see, it's totally OK. He doesn't mind telling you. People are just wait-- they love to talk about themselves, you know? And that's what people want. And they also like to be asked questions that they have answers for. He completely knows the answer to, how many virgins?
——正如你所看到的，这完全没问题。他不介意告诉你。人们只是等——他们喜欢谈论自己，你知道吗？这就是人们想要的。而且他们也喜欢被问到他们有答案的问题。他完全知道“多少个处女”的答案。
So then they feel good about themselves. And they'll keep going. And from there, it's pretty smooth sailing.
所以他们对自己的感觉很好。而且他们会继续聊。从那里开始，就相当顺利了。
The first one that came along was for 2 and 1/2 years.
第一个出现的是两年半。
Really?
真的吗？
That was the first girl I was ever with, though.
不过那是我交往的第一个女孩。
That was?
那是？
She was a virgin, too. We were both virgins. It was good, you know, but it was weird. It was kind of like an all day, all-around-town sort of thing. Because it started at her grandparents' house, which is in this all yellow room. The sheets were yellow. The window curtains were yellow.
她也是处女。我们俩都是处女。这很好，你知道，但这很奇怪。它有点像是一整天、全城转的那种事情。因为它始于她祖父母的家，那在一个全黄色的房间里。床单是黄色的。窗帘是黄色的。
And then it just wasn't working out. So then we drove out to this spot by a drive-in movie screen that was abandoned. But it was a good experience altogether. I enjoyed it.
然后它进展不顺。所以我们就开车去了那个废弃的汽车电影院屏幕旁的地方。但总的来说是一次很好的体验。我很享受。
So that was a minute and 26 seconds. And now, after a minute and 26, through The Rundown, I know what he's had for breakfast, that he's capable of love, how many girls he slept with, how many of them were virgins, who he lost his-- first lost his virginity to, and even the color wallpaper of her grandmother's house. So that's pretty good. That's a pretty successful Rundown.
所以那是一分钟26秒。现在，一分钟26秒之后，通过简报，我知道了他早餐吃了什么，他有能力去爱，他睡过多少女孩，其中多少个是处女，谁是他第一次失去——第一次失去童贞的人，甚至她祖母房子的壁纸颜色。所以这很不错。那是一个相当成功的简报。
And there's a few simple rules for everyone to be able to do it just like this eventually. So the first rule is, number one, small talk is a conversation you're supposed to be having. And The Rundown is a conversation you want to be having. Right?
每个人最终都能像这样做到这一点有几个简单的规则。所以第一条规则是，第一，闲聊是你应该进行的对话。而简报是你想要进行的对话。对吧？
Number two is, why chew the fat, when you can chew the meat? OK?
第二条是，当你可以咀嚼肉的时候，为什么还要嚼那些肥肉呢？好吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
Also very important. Number three is, if you can think it, you can ask it.
这也非常重要。第三条是，如果你能想到，你就能问出来。
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
OK? And then, if all else fails, or even if all else doesn't fail, number four is, how many virgins?
好吗？然后，如果一切都失败了，或者即使一切都没失败，第四条是，多少个处女？
[LAUGHTER]
[大笑]
So that's the run down.
所以那就是简报。
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
[掌声和欢呼]
Starlee Kine, speaking at The Little Gray Book Lectures, at the Galapagos Art Space, in New York. She writes for the HBO Max TV series "Search Party.":
斯塔莉·凯恩，在纽约加拉帕戈斯艺术空间的“小灰书讲座”上发言。她为HBO Max电视系列剧“Search Party”撰稿。
[MUSIC - "IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS" BY EDITH FROST]
[音乐 - 伊迪丝·弗罗斯特的《IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS》]
(SINGING) I'd be writing all day, if it weren't for the words. I'd find something to say, if it weren't for the words. It's the words that give me trouble. I'd be all right if it weren't for the words.
(演唱) 我会整天写作，如果不是因为这些词。我会找到话要说，如果不是因为这些词。是这些词给我带来了麻烦。我会没事的，如果不是因为这些词。
Well, our program was produced today by Sean Cole, Bim Adewunmi, with help from Nadia Reiman. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Damien Grave, Jessica Lussenhop, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Falen, Tracy Rowland, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Managing editor for today's show was Diane Wu. Executive editor was David Kestenbaum; production help with today's rerun from Ari Saperstein and Chloee Weiner.
嗯，我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔、比姆·阿德温米制作，得到了纳迪亚·雷曼的帮助。负责今天节目的人包括埃尔娜·贝克、伊曼纽尔·贝里、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、尼尔·德鲁明、达米安·格雷夫、杰西卡·卢森霍普、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、本·法伦、特雷西·罗兰、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的主编是戴安·吴。执行编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆；来自阿里·萨珀斯坦和克洛伊·韦纳的重播制作帮助。
Special thanks today to Judy Meltzer, Bishop Gene Robinson, Dr. Barry Holtz, Deborah Moore, Hamza Syed, Ahmed Ali Akbar, Zainab Shah, Khalid Latif, Hannah Jewel, Ben Zimmer, Karl Baker, and Tom Howell. Our website-- ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos, lists of favorite shows, for your summer-long car rides, tons of other stuff there-- again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
特别感谢今天的朱迪·梅尔策、吉恩·罗宾逊主教、巴里·霍尔茨博士、黛博拉·摩尔、哈姆扎·赛义德、艾哈迈德·阿里·阿克巴、扎伊纳布·沙赫、哈立德·拉蒂夫、汉娜·朱厄尔、本·齐默、卡尔·贝克和汤姆·豪厄尔。我们的网站——ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以完全免费流媒体收听我们700集节目的档案。还有视频、最受欢迎节目的列表，供你整个夏天的车程，上面还有大量其他内容——再次声明，ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He just saw the film Cool Runnings last week, and he wondered, is that a documentary?
《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他上周刚看了电影《冰上轻舞》，他纳闷，那是一部纪录片吗？
Really the first thing I did was send it to every Jamaican I knew and be like, Yo so what do you think about this
我做的第一件事就是把它发给我认识的每一个牙买加人，说，哟，那你对这个怎么看
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS" BY EDITH FROST]
[音乐 - 伊迪丝·弗罗斯特的《IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS》]
(SINGING) Yeah, yeah, I'd all right, if it weren't for the words. I'd be feeling just fine, if it weren't for the words.
(演唱) 是的，是的，我会没事的，如果不是因为这些词。我会感觉很好，如果不是因为这些词。